so i think the first time that i
realized i needed to
like tangibly do something about it uh
which is the movement that we called
american contingency
outside of my own business was when
uh law enforcement officers in seattle
stopped responding to certain calls
and that happened and then they set up
this capitol hill
movement which became a nightmare and
they basically allowed for
you know disorderly conduct even
criminal activity
that was the first time that we went
okay we need to do something about it i
was just in portland oregon about four
weeks ago four weekends ago
uh the portland authority uh didn't
respond to 60 calls
in a weekend including larceny burglary
even reports of rape
that and that's mind-boggling like to
think that you could be a law-abiding
citizen who pays taxes and that
there's a you know a political
divisiveness that takes place
where it could literally translate to
you not being protected in your own
community
is disturbing
it's locals week here on the reuben
report and i'm doing a bunch of mini
interviews with creators who have
decided to become
less reliant on big tech and instead own
their content community and livelihood
with locals.com
and joining me today is the founder of
field craft survival
and american contingency mike lover
welcome to the reuben report
thanks for having me it's a pleasure
mike i don't know if
anyone else on locals has blown this
thing
up the way that you have you have an
absolutely
huge community on there and i think when
we explain to people what it is you do
on there they'll understand why you're
on locals
so what is the american contingency
locals group all about so i i saw
an inherent need for bringing people
together
without the levels of suppression that
are taking place
across social media so i i do own a
company called phil crafts survival that
specializes in preparedness
and when we started talking about
preparedness in
different venues different settings uh
in training and mindset
audible video etc we started realizing
that
even just talking about preparedness and
self-defense was getting suppressed
because it seemed like it was
risque or it was too fringe which is
surprising to me because i
spent my entire life as a green beret in
special operations
i love america love freedom but i love
passing
information from lessons learned from
overseas
to civilians and so when i started doing
that i started getting routinely
suppressed by every major platform
and realized we need to look to look
somewhere else at the same time
socially we were having problems with um
discourse and you know the breakdown of
law and order
or politicians enforcing law and order
and so i realized
i i needed to provide something that
wasn't going to be suppressed
so i reached out to locals and locals
became our home so
in essence you guys are a community of
preppers and
you're kind of guiding everybody on on
some of the tips and
and tricks of the trade and it's kind of
funny because you're right when when
people think about preppers the
mainstream idea is oh somehow
this is some sort of scary right wing
something and yet we've seen in
what seven months of lockdown a lot of
people became preppers pretty freaking
quick
so you you must be feeling kind of good
about that
yeah things have obviously changed in
our society based on the pandemic
based on the the drama that's taking
place
but we even before all this was taking
place we
advocated for people to be self-reliant
and not depend on the government
or institutions outside of their control
to come
and rescue them you know our saying is
you are your own first response
well now with a political divisiveness
causing
first responders to sometimes never
respond
made us realize that um not only are
your
are you your own first response but you
might have to sustain your
survivability over time so american
tendency was that movement to train
to mentor advise and to provide a
social network for people to come
together and and
to see it happen almost overnight and
the engagement that we have
was uh inspiring to me because i
realized that maybe we were identifying
a problem that
the rest or a lot of americans are
seeing today yeah
it's incredible i'm a member of the
community when i've jumped in there just
to see what the conversation's like
it's like there's no hate there's no
there's no anger there's these are good
people who are just trying to figure out
how to not be so reliant
on the systems that as you as you kind
of said there the systems that
seemingly are failing you know if you're
calling cops and they're not showing up
or whatever it might be well then maybe
you do have to take some of this into
your own hands
when did you get interested in all of
this
so i think the first time that i
realized i needed to
like tangibly do something about it
which is the movement that we called
american contingency
outside of my own business was when
uh law enforcement officers in seattle
stopped responding to certain calls
and that happened and then they set up
this capitol hill
movement which became a nightmare and
they basically allowed for
you know disorderly conduct even
criminal activity
that was the first time that we went
okay we need to do something about it i
was just in portland oregon about four
weeks ago four weekends ago
uh the portland authority uh didn't
respond to 60 calls
in a weekend including larceny burglary
even reports of rape
that and that's mind-boggling like to
think that you could be a law-abiding
citizen who pays taxes and that
there's a you know a political
divisiveness that takes place
where it could literally translate to
you not being protected in your own
community
is disturbing so that that's what led us
down that path
and and so far it's been a positive
experience because
we you know we don't tolerate fringe
actors who want to
um have their own agendas what we want
is a positive
society a positive community and
we don't have we're not going to
tolerate the negative
toxic uh divisiveness that's common
today in our society and on locals it's
your community and you can do whatever
you want with it what kind of
uh censorship stuff were you dealing
with on facebook and some of the other
platforms you kind of alluded to that a
moment ago yeah
the biggest thing is in the in the
algorithm or the
the system that is facebook and
instagram which we
had a lot of our platforms even my
social my own personal social media
influence on
one of the things that is a metric or a
measure for understanding if you're
suppressed
is the inability for people to
organically search you in the search
queue
via your name which is which is common
right like if you look up
right now and i just did this three days
ago if you look up antifa
the word antifa you will get all the
organizations including the
main pages of antifa that aren't
suppressed that populate in the queue
if you look up mike glover you will even
get the people who are pretending to be
in the search queue
but you will not get me and that goes
for a lot of my friends who are
veterans of special operations who are
conservatives
and who aren't fringe anybody that are
just advocating for
the same things we're advocating for and
and those things are apparent
in numbers and analytics and even simple
things like search cue yeah it's
incredible what they do i mean i
i got my own version of that you know if
you search me it's like 10 terrible
articles coming up first all filled with
lies
or you know they'll do you probably have
one of these too when you do
people also search for and it used to
have me associated with all these people
i had never heard of who were these real
fringe actors eventually
i was able to complain enough that i got
some of that stuff fixed
but but in essence you moved over to
locals and you can now do whatever you
want with your community and
and it seems to me that the american
contingency group
that you guys have a double reason to be
there because it's not just that you're
preparing for the worst
in in the real world but you're prepared
for the worst in the digital world too
so it has like a two-pronged piece to it
yeah it it definitely does what i've
realized over time
in this short period of time that we've
been on locals is that there's
a significant education process that's
that needs to take place
in not only advocating for platforms
like locals
but getting people to try to migrate as
a good tenancy
like i get it like if a lot of your
attention span is spent on a platform
like instagram that's going to happen
because
a lot of people are on it but if you set
in place where
you know that you can go suppression
free onto that platform
that's a benef benefit of having this
lined out that way with the overall goal
of transferring platforms and people
just staying on locals
like i already know my platform
eventually will be shut down
i mean it's going to happen and when
that happens we'll do a full migration
but what i do is i dabble or i put out
the snippets of information via there
and then i i
hub my content because i know it's
protected i know it's secure
and i know it's not going to be
moderated or suppressed by people
who i don't know who don't agree with my
message and that's significant for me
as an influencer as a business owner and
as somebody who wants to create a
positive movement because
now i can operate securely i mean i'm
thrilled to hear it man because that's
exactly why we created this thing it's
like it's
it's tools for you to do whatever you
want can you talk a little bit about the
business first because american
contingency is the community
part of this but you had a you had and
have a pretty successful business before
this
that's that sort of spurred this all on
yeah so
you know i i'm open about this but i was
a special operations guy for
nearly my entire life since i was 17
years old um i i went to war nine times
i decided to become a cia contractor
known as a global response staff officer
i served overseas did five or six
additional more rotations in austere
environments
and realized if i wanted to have control
of my life
i couldn't work for the government i
needed to do something different
and in pakistan on my last rotation i
decided to start phil craft survival
i also realized that there's a lot of
things that i learned in special
operations
in process and mindset and rehearsal and
planning and equipment
that didn't have to do with specialized
tactics but just simple processes that
civilians would benefit when looking at
their life not
not only in preparedness but just all
facets of their life even in business
i mean i use simple like the five
paragraph operations order
that i learned as an 18 year old ranger
school student i apply to business
because it's a good way
to process information and to uh
disseminate that information in business
so field craft survival i've had for
about four years now
and we offer training we have podcasts
we have free
valuable information in the realm of
preparedness
trying to kind of get rid of the
stereotypes associated with the prepper
and letting people know it doesn't
matter what political affiliation or
side of the aisle you're on
what's what's uh unique about
catastrophe
is it it's an equal opportunist it
doesn't care what color
ethnicity or where you come from it's
going to destroy your life all the same
so if you're prepared um you'll be
better set up for success instead of
failure
so that's what we do i'm doing it right
now in montana
i have 20 plus employees we subcontract
and contract
all over the united states teaching
civilians military and law enforcement
how to be better prepared yeah can you
tell people just like a couple of the
little tips for the people that are just
sort of wading into these waters because
of lockdown as we said because of seeing
violence things like that it's
interesting because i never
considered myself a prepper we do have
some emergency kits and stuff like that
but i always liked having
like a lot of canned goods in the
basement or in the pantry like just you
know extra water
paper towels that kind of stuff i never
thought of it as prepper really but it
was always
like yeah if all hell broke loose for a
couple days i'm in the politics world
it's like
you can't not think of that but i think
a lot of people are just for the first
time ever going oh
you mean i gotta not take out from a
restaurant every night you go i got to
have some food here i got to have some
water here
what are what are like some of the 101
type things that you recommend to people
when they're just learning about this
yeah i think when i look at preparedness
i look at statistical probability
so i don't want to paint a picture like
a doomsday scenario
but when you you know when i was asked
two two years ago in a podcast with a
buddy of mine mike pfeiffer
he asked me what is the worst case
scenario and i said simply
the worst case scenario is a large-scale
pandemic with
social disruption chaos or discourse
and that's exactly what we're facing
right now and and
it's because uh right now when you take
and stack
social economic issues on top of each
other it it destroys the
fabric or structure or in our case
security that we feel
so what people could understand first
and foremost is that your mindset
or your your level of resilience in your
mindset is the most important thing you
can focus on
because you know disastrous catastrophe
come at you in different spurts of time
and space
and if it hits you in the face like a
baseball bat and sometimes maybe that's
literally then that's a compressed
timeline but if you have something like
a pandemic it's a long duration timeline
well ultimately if you understand how
you respond to stress because that's
what you're reacting to
then you have a good idea how you're
going to manage the process
of a disaster or catastrophe so it
starts with mindset
so being healthy um
making your family healthy getting sleep
taking care of your immunity um eating
healthy uh and getting exercise are
basic start points that people
would never consider in a preparedness
or a prepper movement
but that's the start point because when
you're healthy physically and mentally
then you're able to make good cognitive
decisions to set yourself up for success
just a tangible takeaway for for your
listeners
tourniquets are one of the most
important pieces of equipment that are
neglected
you could die from a femoral or
breakable bleed which is a large
arterial bleed
in a matter of minutes i've seen it on
the battlefield i've even seen it in
america
happen in vehicle accidents 30 000
people a year in america die from car
accidents
and it's one simple 29.99
thing that you could buy online get
trained put it in your car put in your
wife's purse put it in your pocket
and carry it with you because if you
learn to have that life-saving
piece of equipment it could save your
life and it's and it only improves
the overall life that you do have
because people think that people who are
prepared are paranoid it's the complete
opposite
you're not anxious you're not paranoid
you're confident
in living your life yeah i love that and
it's just it's just so
obvious after the last couple months
that people who thought about some of
this stuff
seriously from taking care of yourself
physically and mentally to having some
supplies and everything else
they're in a much better spot than the
people that thought that the systems
were always going to exist
um well listen i i was i was going to
tell you to pimp out the american
contingency community but i think you've
done a hell of a job
doing it but but where can people go to
to join your local community
so the best link for us is
americancontingency.locals.com and
that's a great start point
i also have a personal youtube i'm doing
this show called
living your prep life which is a
spin-off living your best life
yeah but i think the best life is a prep
life uh you can go to youtube and find
me under my personal which is just
simply mike
glover which so far there's no
suppression on that channel
all right well mike i i know my audience
is going to love this so i want to have
you on for a proper hour long sit down
so we'll do that
over the next month or two maybe right
after the election once we see what
level of freak out everybody's in
i might need some personal advice myself
i would love that it would be an honor
all right thanks man well i really
appreciate it and truly for
for you guys that haven't checked out
the community it's just unbelievable
what you're doing on there
and it's americancontingency.org
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell